hey youtubers it's Charlie so so much
happened during the arrow finale they
tied up most of the important stuff left
us hanging on a few big things and gave
us a pretty good idea for where season 3
is going so here's what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna start with my top 5 moments then
do my review and then do season 3
theories if you're finding me for the
first time I do arrow videos every week
- also because it's going on hey this
now I'm going to be doing arrow and
flash bonus videos probably every
Wednesday be sure to subscribe to get
everything and leave me suggestions for
bonus videos so careful for spoilers
from the episode if you haven't seen it
yet but here are my top 5 moments number
five Roy gets his suit that speech
Oliver gave him was the same speech
Barry gave to Oliver back in episode 9
during the flash crossover that's when
Barry gave Oliver his green mask
Roy's mirakuru crash-and-burn is going
to inform his character in season 3 and
since Thea's gone he's definitely
sticking around you know you don't get a
hero shot like he did in the tunnel and
they just dumped the character although
there have been some live-action Young
Justice rumors I really do like the
costume obviously it's still kind of
like that plain hoodie that he's
plugging to keep wearing the red hoodie
it's really the mask that makes it the
costume I think he's using the same type
of bow and arrows that Oliver's using so
they're just gonna have to order double
from now on whenever they restock number
four Thea goes with Merlyn I think we
expected this a little bit but I had no
idea what was gonna push her over that
ledge and it turned out to be the
revelation that Roy was just lying about
his relationship with arrow there's a
whole lot we can unpack in the comments
but the big takeaway here is that she's
toughening up like she's on the same
character arc Sara was on whenever she
joined the League of Assassins whenever
she started to become Black Canary she's
becoming the badass evil daughter that
Merlyn always wanted from a comics
character standpoint I think she's gonna
train with Merlyn and become the Artemis
character I think it just makes the most
sense based on Merlyn skills and her
background I'll talk more about that in
my season 3 theories but she still does
not know who the arrow is and now that
she's gonna turn into this stone-cold
killer it's possible that she and Merlyn
could become the season 3 antagonists
here's a really important thing though
Merlyn has not told her who the arrow is
and she doesn't know that it's Oliver so
is he gonna do that or are they gonna
leave that for like a season 3 reveal
moment you know like a reunion where she
finds out that it's Oliver
three amanda waller versus the suicide
squad because we got so much amanda
waller this season and given LYLAS new
baby and that post-credits flashback
scene I think it's safe to say we're
going to see a whole lot of them Knicks
season the squad is probably going to
evolve with a new member - and we'll
learn more about all of our history with
them Diggle and Oliver are also fathers
now which is a really weird thing I
thought season 3 would play into the
sins of the father theme even more just
based on Merlyn and Thea and Oliver and
his son but adding Diggle to that baby
list just makes it almost certain which
means we're pretty much guaranteed to
meet Felicity's father which I'm really
excited for but even more fun is going
to be revisiting Waller and Oliver's
pre-existing relationship it sounds like
she either contracted him for special
missions or something to do with the
list so Waller is going to be the island
of season 3 you know even though we
still have a link to the real Island
plan on them revealing a lot more about
Amanda Waller's character - we've
already learned that she really likes to
take dudes to the Austria and her sweet
number - Slade took the wrong woman this
was a total fake out but I loved the way
it played out start to finish I think
Twitter exploded when they had that I
love you moment it was all just clever
editing and Felicity was in on the
fake-out the whole time but boy did they
take a long time to pay off that secret
camera plot remember that was way back
in the promise episode and I love the
way that they followed that moment up
when they were on the beach and Oliver
reacted in this way that made you think
like yeah he may not have been acting he
may actually really love her I think he
does love her just maybe not in a
completely romantic way and my number
one moment
Slade helps Oliver become a hero this
all goes back to the heroes don't kill
people thing it's just Oliver
getting closer to that Justice League
level of hero Slade taught him that he
can defeat evil without killing that
there's a better way to do things that's
why whenever they were jumping back and
forth between the flashbacks
Oliver ended the flashback scene by
throwing the serum away and trying to
stab him consider that his low point
they never really addressed Slade's you
know shadow hallucinations other than to
say that he hated Oliver before he
started hallucinating shado like she was
not the reason that he started hating
him the big teaser now is that he's
tucked away in Argus's new supermax
prison on the island I guess they're
calling it purgatory for now
in case you didn't catch the reference
whenever Oliver said there will be more
he meant they would fight more
Deathstroke level supervillains and
stick them in that underground prison -
I think eventually we'll get to the
situation where things on arrow just
escalate season to season until we get
to like season 6 or 7 or whenever the
final season is and then they'll be like
an Arkham prison break-out like this
place is arrows version arkham prison so
naturally what do you do when you fill
Arkham prism up
well you bust everyone out all at the
same time Prison Break in Justice
Society edition I'm calling it now
that's how the series is ending but now
it's your turn let me know what your
favorite moment was and do you think the
Theia is gonna be one of the villains
next season or at least one of the
antagonists like she's gonna be a bad
person I have to say my funniest moment
was probably Felicity versus Nyssa in
the Battle of introductions felicity
smoak MIT class of O 9 overall the
episode was a solid a it did a great job
of capping off a season that just
continued to escalate the stakes to
infinity each week and at the same time
did an amazing job of setting up season
3 in this really exciting way don't you
feel if you just took some of the key
scenes from the last 15 minutes of the
episode and cut them together it would
be like a perfect season 3 trailer you
have thean Merlin's new Ark Roy as up
fully realized Arsenal and team arrow
moving to a new location with babies and
Amanda Waller off to the side just
staring daggers at everyone the only
thing that I wish they'd spent more time
on were Slade in Oliver's final moments
you know they're really dramatic moments
not the fight scenes and we did get a
peek into Slade's mind during episode 18
whenever we learned about the existence
of evil
Tinkerbell shado but they might be
saving a lot of that cerebral Slade for
season 3 and beyond he's definitely
coming back at some point I think it
would be totally funny if they did like
a blacklist thing wherever Slade starts
helping out a woman on Argus's team who
just happens to be his daughter
just like he's the James Spader
character onto Lauryn Thea I was really
impressed with what they did with these
two characters they had the biggest
transformations this season obviously
Thea's really kind of just happened in
the last couple of episodes and as for
the jacket that Laurel had is definitely
the most on-the-nose reference to the
comics you know especially Quentin's
response you know not yet I think it
just means that Laurel is not gonna be
the Black Canary for at least one more
year
think about how long it took Roy to
become red arrow whenever he said on the
path basically all season but all that
aside the thing that I'm most excited
about is Thea and Merlyn I think they're
way more exciting than all of her son
but let's talk some season three now so
I'm just gonna blast through all these
and then we can just pick them apart in
the comments starting with the new arrow
cave the foundry was trashed Thea
doesn't own it anymore and she's left
town so they're definitely not going
back there cut to that other site that
Oliver went to during Moira's funeral
then there's getting the company back
I'm not expecting Oliver to be mayor but
they might do that or they'll do it like
in the comics wherever Oliver created a
new company and then that company just
buys back Queen industries you know new
arrow cave new company that kind of
seems like it could fit then there's
Thea as Artemis she'll probably have
like a season long arc or she becomes a
version of the dark Archer you know like
father like daughter it's possible that
they could become the season 3 villains
or at least the antagonist for team
arrow because Merlyn is just a little
bit evil next up flash crossover we saw
the trailer during the episode and
Stephen Amell was helping Barry Train
plan on him and Felicity at least being
in the flash episode 1 and there to be
at least one or two direct crossovers
they will have a shared universe though
sidestep to Argus Suicide Squad and
Amanda Waller they're all going to
continue to interact with team arrow at
least a couple times this season and now
that we have Lila and diggle's baby it's
just one more reason to throw them in a
story you know she's Argus so any
episode that Lyla is in automatically
becomes a backdoor Suicide Squad Amanda
Waller episode which leads me to
flashbacks now that we know that Oliver
spent time with Amanda Waller after he
left the island but before he returned
to Starling all the new flashback
moments will just pull from that time
period I'm thinking Oliver Argus agent
and Chyna type stuff you know more
opportunities for him to bump into new
villains in the past
next up baby mama time the mother of
Oliver's child moved to Central City
he'll probably learn more about them and
it'll probably be part of a flash
crossover also dinkles baby will
probably get tied up in some new plot to
he's not leaving the team and Lyla is
not quitting Argus and the League of
Assassins in the canary will probably
cameo at least once I'm hoping team
arrow actually ends up going on a road
to Nanda Parbat that would just be
amazing so that's pretty much it if you
think I forgot anything just write it
below in the comments but if you didn't
see it I just posted a breakdown on the
new flash trailer that's a separate
video and I'll be posting that Q&A
tomorrow so leave me all your questions
about the flash and the arrow because
I'm just gonna be combining those two
things right now you can click here to
get that flash trailer and you can click
here to get the Q&A I'll add the
annotation as soon as I post the video
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you guys tomorrow
high fives
you